hey guys Pete here Game of Thrones
Season 7 News has been filtering out
since the show started filming in
Belfast and last night I saw a post that
will definitely get fans excited but it
relates to production news so if you
don't like to have spoilers from casting
or the set you should probably stop
watching but before you go I'm doing a
book giveaway so check out one of my
other new Game of Thrones videos to
participate in that everyone else make
sure you watch to the end to find out
how to enter ok so there isn't a ton of
news so far this week but we can do a
lot of speculation on what the biggest
reveal might mean we'll get into that in
a minute but first let's look at the
less shocking but still exciting news
Ian's gland has been spotted by fans in
Belfast which means that we can expect
to see Jorah again this season there was
a rumor of him coming to town earlier
this year with Gwendoline Christie but
this new photo seals the deal I always
expected we would see more Jorah since
he had that scene with Dany where she
tells him to go find a cure for his
greyscale but I guess some fans were
wondering if that would be the last we
would see of it show Jorah is a lot
different of a character than the book
jour is and he's a little bit more
likable on the show less rough looking
and most importantly he doesn't have
stray scale in the books where he's that
now is a combination of two different
characters one of which we will never
really see in the show so it's a bit
complicated to speculate on his role
generally speaking though we know his
purpose in life is to serve Dany even if
that means that his love for her remains
unrequited he has faced great risk to
come back to her and now she's given him
a direct order to find a cure and come
back to her heal my guess is that he
will find something of value for her in
his quest to heal himself the progress
of the greyscale seems steady but slow
so it's possible he could survive for a
while it would make sense for him to go
east and then you know that would open a
lot of doors and in the way of him
finding something that could be of value
to her in her quest later my personal
hope is that he will run into Quaithe
but the show hasn't used her much and
she's a lot bigger of a character in the
books it would be cool since Quaithe is
a really interesting character it is
important but not exactly sure why he
would need to run into her face to face
if you don't remember Cuesta's the mask
shadow binder woman Dany met in Qarth
that actually approached Jorah first and
you know she gives Dany some help and
some profit
see that is pretty important in the
books Quaithe communicates with Danny
and dreams and there is a high
likelihood that she is secretly another
character from the past I always like
the shardene theory since I think ishara
has more of a role to play in the story
but other theories say she's shear a sea
star who is one of the great bastards
that's a sister to Bloodraven if he
doesn't run into Quaithe maybe he finds
out something about the warlocks from
the house of the undying there's a
possibility that since you're on Greyjoy
is getting into the mix that they might
be important but I am working on a your
own video that will get into that so I'm
not really going to talk about that here
let me know what you guys think about
where Jorah will end up and what he'll
do I mentioned in my last season 7th
video that we are getting confirmed
battle at sea that pits the Greyjoy's
against one another we also have news
that they are casting for other battles
which means a season looks like there's
going to be a whole lot of stuff going
on Watchers on the wall reported the
Game of Thrones is casting hundreds of
extras in Spain they have pretty strict
rules which include no visible tattoos
or modern hairstyles it's also been
mentioned that the male's must be
willing to shave their heads and beard
so this sounds a lot like an unsullied
army watchers also reported that the
crew is looking for a large number of
forces in that area which means we're
likely going to get a battle that
involves both the unsullied and the
Dothraki on Westerosi soil the big news
of course isn't that sophie Turner
Maisie Williams have been spotted
shopping getting tattoos together in
Belfast it involves our favorite lost
character of the series Kendrick the
last we saw him he was rowing away after
Davos saved him from Melisandre back in
season 3 and fans have not forgotten him
he has been subject of a ton of
speculation but the star of some awesome
memes and now we have confirmation that
Joe Dempsie the actor who plays ginjury
has been spotted at an airport in
Belfast this is fun news since we all
have wondered just where Gendry might
have been hanging out all this time his
character is another example of mixing
two characters from the books together
though
we actually know where Gendry is in the
books Brienne runs into him at the end
at the crossroads and the Riverlands
he's working there with the Brotherhood
without banners who are currently
following Lady Stoneheart around in the
books
the Brotherhood never sell gained Rita
Melisandre like we see in this show in
season 3 so he's just always been there
since you know him and Aria parted ways
Melisandre still does the blood
sacrifice with the leeches and all that
but she used a different Baratheon
bastard who's named
Edric storm ed ryx different than um
Gendry sons he's he's like noted as one
of Roberts sons and he's been at
Dragonstone since he was born he's the
one that Davos saves and in the story in
the books he sends him off to the Free
Cities in the end that isn't really that
important because to date we haven't
heard much about him either so what can
we speculate based on knowing Gendry is
coming back well as mentioned he won't
be doing what either of the characters
he is based on is doing in the books I
mean not likely anyways we know that
Lady Stoneheart got cut from the show
and since the Brotherhood sold him off
it isn't likely that he'll be joining
back up with them anytime soon he is the
last you know remaining person that we
know that has you know Roberts Ludd but
do we really think with so few episodes
left that the show will have some houses
rally around him and the Stormlands and
go against the crown me it's possible it
just seems like it might be unnecessary
at this point since we're headed towards
the war for the dawn think what makes
the most sense is that since Arya is
back in Westeros we will see them meet
up again let's not forget that
Melisandre has headed south now that Jon
sent her away so a confluence of these
three characters might be in the works
after all Melisandre told Arya that they
would meet again and in the show story
Gendry is most important for these two
characters if he's going to play a major
role is yet to be seen but D&D no fans
want to see Kendrick come back and a
reunion with Daario would be a good
payoff so he could play a role or it
could just be fanservice to tie up that
loose end and they could maybe just get
together and that'd be it I won't go too
far into predictions for Arya Melisandre
since I'll be doing that in a different
video but at least now we know that the
rower that was promised is going to make
an appearance let me know what part you
guys think and reply in season 7 or what
you'd like to see between these three
characters before I go I wanted to give
a shout out to a new channel that is
doing some cool stuff for charity it's
called trial by trivia and they've been
doing Game of Thrones tribute which is
actually a lot of fun I came across
their channel the Saturday night and had
a blast answering questions in the chat
room
there are other subscribers they've also
been doing a tournament where YouTube
creators that you probably know go
against each other like head-to-head so
you can watch those episodes to see how
well you might be able to do against
them it's a brand new channel so they're
still growing but the charity aspect is
great and you should definitely check
them out I'll post a link in the
description below so check them out and
think about supporting the charity which
is a I can't remember the name right now
but it trains service dogs to help
people get them that need them please
like this video if you thought it was
good and make sure to subscribe to my
channel for a chance to win in the
giveaway when I hit 18,000 subscribers
I'm giving away a copy of a night of the
seven kingdoms by george RR martin all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on my
videos thanks for watching and I will
talk to you soon